imagining at this point that you were a
huge deal at comic-con
because
of your body of work and then you're
doing these iron man films and you go to
comic-con and that is that is just a
molten hot core of nerdum that is it is
it is nerd central and my biggest
contribution actually was in iron man 2
we had the iron maidens or ironettes the
costumes where they wore the uh
sort of red metallic bikinis when iron
man was on stage because
there's cosplay yeah people dressing up
and costumes is a big part of the the
geek culture i believe we have a photo
of the iron nets that you took there
they are these are the iron nets and you
took them to comic con no but now what
people do is they imitate and dress up
like that oh they dress like so the
attractive nerd lets
pets
now their dads have options beyond just
lara croft and
slave leia yeah
you know what i was talking about
when i went to comic-con everyone they
need something else because everyone is
slave leia yeah everybody is slave some
dudes guys are slaves
i actually shaved my back last year so i
could uh i saw you
you were fantastically part of the
what restaurant were you in was that
club 33 or the blue no it was it was at
a in a hotel uh oh property yeah yeah
nice because there's a cocktail in the
picture and that would not be in the
magic in uh club 33 it was well there's
no drinking in the magic kingdom there's
one secret place that apparently club 33
yeah or you take the monorail back to
the hotel and tell the kids you're uh
changing your shoes and come back
tie
[Laughter]
by the way disney is the studio that's
bringing us uh iron man three
coming into theaters we're sorry to
change the subject
yeah they won't pay for my limo back to
the house if i don't at least mention
three nobody apparently has heard of it
yet oh so i'm here
yeah you directed the first two i did
iron man's in this one uh you're you're
you're solely acting in it which must
actually in a weird way feel like a
little bit of a break i'm an executive
producer as well yes so i'm like a proud
grandfather yes and much like my
grandfather when he visits me
i play with the baby when it laughs and
when it craps itself i hand it back to
mommy right so yeah so i would think the
pressure in a nice way if someone else
is directing it and you had to direct
the first two now you get to just well i
get to ham it up on on screen which you
remember from the old days sure how i
started yeah so uh that was uh yeah so i
get to have a good time as a character
actor playing happy hogan in the movie
but then also you know it's a family of
a lot of the people who are working on
it were working on the first two and
shane black who's the director who did a
fine job on this film
uh was involved creatively behind the
scenes on the first film so it really
feels like you're kind of going back to
an old school but it's also nice as a
director to actually be able to leave
the set which is an experience i've
never had an iron man movie i've always
been like 20 hour days as an actor you
mean like now that you're not directing
it you can just take off
get to the disney monorail and get drunk
yeah and in my trailer the actors are
allowed to you know
towards the end of the day after lunch
you're allowed to have a few nips
sometimes before lunch sometimes before
breakfast uh
we have a clip here
from iron man 3 i believe this is a
scene with the uh gwyneth paltrow yes i
said find the scene with no explosions
and nothing exciting happening so let's
see what they came up with yeah this is
let's take a look let's put from iron
man why waste them this is an asset that
we can put to use uh-huh so you're
suggesting that i replace the entire
janitorial stuff with robots what i'm
saying is that the human element of
human resources is our biggest point of
vulnerability we should start phasing it
out immediately
what excuse me bambi hello did you just
say that security happy okay i am
thrilled that you are now the head of
security okay it is the perfect position
for you thank you however i do
appreciate it since you've taken the
post you don't have to think we've had a
rise in staff complaints of 300 percent
thank you
it's not a compliment it's not a co it
is a compliment clearly somebody's
trying to hide something excuse me yes
this pots your four o'clock is here
did you clear this four o'clock with me
yes
[Applause]